[Music]
okay I got her she's out why isn't she
crying the baby's crying I need to go
get her Kristen there is no baby I don't
ever want to see you again why would you
have to get you help you if I don't need
help I just want you out get out
you're pregnant yeah you're not gonna
believe this but you can't be pregnant
though our babies are gonna be best
friends can I do
sorry all right it's very sensitive
right now oh look at a little dude she
looks like a child promise me that
you'll drive safely I promise
I'm so sorry but your wife didn't make
it where's my baby there was a baby I'm
so sorry but anyone want to hurt your
wife
no let's comfort each other in our grief
I'm sorry so who's the father that's
none of your business this is alive it's
not possible for you to give birth
anymore oh really so how did this happen
don't you realize that she's been faking
it the whole time are you hiding
something no I'm not hiding anything I
just don't know what you want from me
we haven't found Julia well maybe you
didn't search the ravine well enough
julia was abducted
give me back my child
you
you